hello everyone and welcome back to the
semifinals of the feeder Grand Prix it's
way Eva's David navara they are battling
it out to see who both face the an
opponent in the finals of the feeder
gram print so the to classical games
between the two of them have been run in
the first game where the Navara had the
white pieces ended in a draw and this is
the second game of the rapids so
something might have happened here and
we also have a very nice photo of this
moment when out of this moment it's a
photo of the previous game where navara
had the white pieces there we have it so
let's just enjoy that for a moment you
can see both players are in in in good
spirits you know really ready to fight
very very excited to be here
so let's let's just enjoy that and now
let us check out the game this photo is
like every photo we've shown from the
video Grand Prix is courtesy of Nikki
Riga official photographer so let's
check out the game wayy with the white
pieces opens with Knight to f3 the reti
opening is on the board with d5 and b3
add the names o Larson attack the ship
to f5 black uses this opportunity to
develop his light square bishop which is
more often than not a difficulty for
black Bishop to b2 end now east 6 with
d3 bite wayy h6 and Knight B to d2
we have Knight to f6 just the continuing
development in the g3 way he will now
feel get out the other Bishop as well c5
and now comes the night study 5 an
excellent outpost for tonight and here
Bishop to e7 is a known move but Knight
B to d7 is what navara plays and it is
as of move 7 that we have a completely
new game so the knight on e5 is being
challenged and now efore so what can
black do here are you obviously don't
again anything by capturing so Bishop
back to h7 with nightcap force on b7
Queen capped for Sun b7 and now Bishop
to g2 fee and catering delights worship
and preparing the Castle kingside
we have Queen back to d8 and this is a
really weird moment of the game one
would imagine that you would just
continue Bishop to e7 castles King side
and well something
in those lines or maybe even d4 to make
the black whites the darks where there
should be useless for a while but here
Queen to d8 by navara and I I didn't
give it much thought but I did give it
some thought and I really don't see the
well not deep well the importance of
this move it's just maybe if you wanted
to Rima new ver the Knight to e5
although that I don't see that happening
or maybe if you wanted the Queen to be
guarding the night so if the shrub
captures you can capture with the Queen
so maybe you can develop the bishop this
way but then again you can't do to e5 so
Queen Queen to d8 is a real mystery and
when ye takes a good advantage of this
mystery he plays he captures on d5 he
captures and now Queenie to check now
the point is if you block with the Queen
let's say Queen e7 just Bishop
characters on f6 you remove the defender
of the d5 square G G captures now after
captures captures you eliminate the d5
point as well and now you're up upon and
black's pawn structure is all messed up
should be a winning winning game for
white so after Queen need to check with
Bishop to e7 and now Bishop captures on
f6 ruining black's pawn structure but on
the other hand black does keep the
bishop there and here we just castles
he's not afraid of the semi-open G file
as g3 is already here in the light
square Bishop will be very helpful in
defending the White King with Bishop to
f5 now getting the bishop back inter
game also maybe now it wouldn't be that
awful to have the Queen and d7 it's it's
a real mystery why the Queen to d8 was
played but okay we have rook 81 now
putting pressure along the e file and
now Bishop to e6 now the bishop has come
out of the cage again and now it's
nicely protecting the black king but
Queen to h5 and already this introduces
the threat from the thumbnail rook
captures an e6 of course is the threat
as you will not be able to recapture the
F pawn is pinned so Queen back to d7 now
really weird stuff happening here the
Queen returns you know where the Queen
should have been all along but feel
free to pause the video here and try to
figure out how to continue this attack
with white while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations as the
hint was in the thumbnail and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it's route capture sunny six still it
doesn't matter that the Queen defends it
because now you can see that both the
Queen and the bishop attack the d5 pawn
and after the shock after Sun d5 df7
will be under attack
so Queen captures and Bishop captures on
d5 we have Queen to d7 again the Queen
returns to d7 and now Bishop captures on
f7 probably it's more precise than Queen
captures on f7 because this allows the
King to kind of wiggle out White is of
course still better but after rook to e1
you can go rook to f8 push back the
Queen we need five king c7 and maybe
just maybe you will be able to prolong
this perhaps if white will not play
perfect move then maybe we will be able
to survive so that's why Bishop
characters on f7 the Queen will be more
useful on h5 we have King today if King
to f8 then you just go rook e1 and
neither of the rooks is ever seen the
light of day so after Bishop captures an
f7 with King to d8 and now rook to e1
you have to bring the rook into the game
kink the c7 of course you want to bring
the rook into the game and the Bishop to
e6 now we have Queen to d8 and now
Knight to c4 bringing the knight into
the game and now the question is can you
play b5 here to force the knight back
but then you you would get Bishop to d5
and now okay
if you capture the knight and Bishop
captures rook and you cannot recapture
because of rook captures on e7 with
check so here it would have to go rook
c8 and then we'd have Queen to f7 again
with a double attack on the dis shop
rook to e8 and now Knight to a5
introducing the threat of rookie six to
c6 and here it would be very difficult
for for black to do anything really
so after this Knight to c4 move with a
six by black instead but now best of the
d5 preventing b5 so look the a7 again in
reducing b5 as a potential move with
Queen to f7 again creating this double
attack towards the Bishop rook to e8 and
now Bishop back to f3 so what do you
what do you do here we have b5 as this
is what Blackwood was hoping for but now
Knight to a5 and now the c6 square is
available for the for the knight the
bishop nicely defends it and it's not
it's not that easy to find a move you
don't even have to play this you can
still go for the rookie six to c6
maneuver and if this land is just over
you cannot block with the bursar to do
to the pin the bishop slices all the way
here the knife covers these squares it's
just gonna be over so here
Navarro tried King to b6 with an attack
on the night and here now we just played
Knight to c6 and it was in this position
unmoved 27 that David Nabarro
resigned the game and with this
resignation he is eliminated from the
Fida Grand Prix and way he advances to
the finals where he will face you on a
pony she for the for for the number one
place in the feeder Grand Prix away ye I
don't know how I don't think he yeah he
cannot qualify for the candidates
tournament even if he wins but as for
neppo if he wins he's definitely in the
candidates tournament so we're
definitely gonna check out the finals
and I thought maybe instead of Knight to
c6 I thought maybe you could for
something with rookie six king captures
an a3 but it's a black gets a lot of
play and you would probably still win
this with white but you don't have
anything forced otherwise away you would
have played it but I just thought I
thought maybe some of you were
interested if this works let's say you
go rook f8 Queen to h7 and now well you
will probably win this game but this is
just much faster after Knight to c6 well
we played at the rook is under attack
the Queen is under attack there's a
triple attack on the bishop here and
just well whatever you do it's just
completely winning for white yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Camilla I would like
to think I'm showing Jeff ski for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it and comment
also asked if I played the League of
Legend
he's somewhere read that I used to play
it I don't play it anymore
somewhere around season three I believe
I managed to get gold one
maybe qualifications for platinum but I
stopped playing I still play that
somewhat if just for fun but I
completely stopped playing after they
reworked Katarina I mean Katarina and
well once they reworked her I I didn't
enjoy it I didn't feel like learning
everything like again and then I decided
I'm too old for that
so I don't play it anymore but my my you
west account is being used by my friends
so if you sometimes see a team oh and I
got mad or you know about a little team
oh that that's not me I don't play that
that little rat but yeah and also
comment wanted to know if what do I
think about the TFT games and the white
well in general and you know how they
call them Auto chess I don't know why
they call them Auto chess it doesn't
really have anything to do with chess
other than the fact that it's played on
a board but I don't know it's a catchy
name so I guess that's why they're doing
it and I haven't really tried all all
that many I tried DOTA out to just once
I didn't really enjoy it and I I've
tried the hearthstone battlegrounds now
and okay that's I found that enjoyable
but I haven't played it much I played a
few games so I can't really say but yeah
I just wanted to mention that as well so
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the fede Grand Prix and the
Sun wastages will we have to see how
Chucky does against core above checking
up on your wonderful suggestions and as
always whatever else happens in the
chess world so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day